[Music]
all right so first off we have to start
with the obvious one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
gay
he didn't even
Flinch
nothing all right people here we go it
is January 15th Iowa caucus Day in the
year 2024 I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report we are live streaming on
rumble on locals on YouTube postgame
show Ruben report.
locals.com and and yes you already know
the theme of the show today it is
finally here the Iowa caucus we will
finally get some sense if polls are
right if people will get out there when
it's extremely can I get the temperature
in Iowa right now it is extremely
extremely cold they're going through a
major cold snap will that depress the
vote who does that help who does that
hurt all of the stuff the last minute
fighting the last minute lying the last
minute grifting it's all here we're
going to cover all of that I think I
have tried over the last uh let's say
six months or so in this primary season
to to say it it all as straight up as I
possibly can obviously I think the
santis is is the best choice for the
Republicans and for the nation if we are
going to get past any of the BS that we
are constantly stuck in uh but Trump if
if we're to believe the polls Trump is
up by an awful lot seems like VC might
have made some gains so now Trump is
going after VC where does Nikki fit into
all of that it is is that right did I
just read that right it is -7 degrees
right now in Iowa now Iowans are are
strong people and they're used to
getting out there in the cold uh we will
see though it might affect the voting a
little bit you know if it's -7 and let's
say you're 82 years old uh you might not
get out that day older people tend to
vote who does that hurt who does that
help anyway the rubric not the Reuben
the rubric for today's show uh is who is
the most America First out of these
people and who can actually beat Biden
and the Democrats those are the two
things right are you America first right
we need to fix the problems of this
country the economy the Border foreign
policy everything right we've got to
focus on America okay that's number one
and number two who can actually win who
can beat the elderly man pretending to
be president who can beat the machine
who has a track record of doing all of
those things uh you may remember we're
going to show you a little clip of of it
at the end uh Ronald Reagan's very
famous speech a time for choosing well
this is it this is it and I just want to
say before we begin one little uh
special message to those of you who are
watching in Iowa I don't know how many
of you are watching in Iowa right now
how incredible is it that you have a
disproportionate chance to actually
affect things right now I think we
checked the numbers on Thursday or
Friday it sounds like about 200,000
people vote are part of these caucuses
right and it's like you have a chance to
really do something right and because of
the nature of the caucus it's not just
walking into a booth and pulling
something and a little curtain opening
up right it's not just checking off
something or tapping something you
actually can talk to your friends your
family the people in your community the
people you go to church with etc etc
when you get into that gymnasium this
afternoon into this evening and you can
convince people you can help pull people
who are wavering one way or another and
you can and you can really fight for
what you believe in it is the most
beautiful American thing possible we
should probably do more voting by caucus
and if you are in Iowa I hope you will
get out there and do your thing so okay
let's we're going to get into some of
the drama because there was a whole
bunch of drama this weekend and then
we're going to get into the nuts and
bolts a little a little time machine
covering what some of these guys have
been up to and uh and then as I said a
little Ronald Reagan to take us out the
big thing over the weekend was that
finally finally Donald Trump went after
VC ramaswami now the thing is said for a
while that it seemed to me that VC and
Trump had made a deal because VC was
always going after everyone else mostly
disantis especially at the beginning and
never going after Trump now we're over
the weekend we're a day or two before
the caucus and suddenly Trump maybe he's
going oh I'm not exactly sure how those
polls are looking be does have a little
bit of steam here I better put an end to
that because the people that like VC are
the same people that like Trump right so
if if V's getting any votes it seems
like it's coming out of the Trump uh out
of that Trump base so on Truth social
Donald Trump posted this over the
weekend VC started his campaign as a
great supporter the best president in
Generations Etc unfortunately now all he
does is disguise his support in the form
of deceitful campaign tricks very Sly
but a vote for VC is a vote for the
other side don't get duped by this vote
for Trump don't waste your vote be is
not Maga the Biden indictments against
his political opponent will never be
allowed in this country they are already
beginning to fall Maga okay so a little
bit of drama there because it's it's
just I don't have the evidence I don't
have the piece of paper that says they
had the call here and this is when it
happened but I think most people who are
sober thinkers about this realize there
was some coordination between VC and
Trump right like VC I'm never going to
attack you at the debates I'm never
going to go after you I'll take out the
other guys like am I really running for
president if you're supposedly 50 points
up and I'm only attacking the people
that are in that other section with me
right Nikki uh Dan santis Etc anyway
there was uh about an hour on Twitter
where people were going holy is V GNA
actually respond to this like what's
going on here and VC did respond here it
is yes I saw president Trump's truth
social post it's an unfortunate move by
his campaign advisers I don't think
Friendly Fire is help ful Donald Trump
was the greatest president of the 21st
century and I'm not going to criticize
him in response to this late attack I've
met tens of thousands of Ians across 390
plus events here and they are deeply
worried and so am I that this system
won't allow Donald J Trump anywhere near
the White House again it seems they will
stop at nothing to keep him away from
Power I'm worried for Trump I'm worried
for our country I've stood up against
the persecutions against Trump and I've
defended him at every step I showed up
at the Miami Courthouse in solidarity
following his First Federal indictment I
followed a foia
demand for uh to the department uh the
Biden doj I submitted an amicus brief
this week with the US Supreme Court
calling on them to overturn Colorado's
ruling I pledge to remove myself from
Maine in Colorado's primary ballots if
they remove Trump calling on Dan santis
and Haley to do the same but we have to
open our eyes last time it was a
man-made pandemic and big Tech election
interference now the same billionaires
funding the lawsuits against Trump are
the ones trying to prop up Nikki Haley
the same mainstream Media Blasting Trump
is lavishing Praise on Nikki they want
to narrow this race to a a two-horse
race between Trump and Haley eliminate
Trump one way or another and trot their
puppet into the White House we can't
fall for that trap one year from now we
won't look back and say we were shocked
that we let it happen we'll kick
ourselves for not stopping it our
movement must live on America first
didn't start in 2016 it started in 1776
we owee it to our founding fathers to do
the right thing for our country I want
to save Trump and save this country
let's do it together you won't hear any
any friendly fire from me okay so
there's a couple interesting things here
and then I'll get some other people's
responses on it uh first off that this
idea of Friendly Fire VC has been
attacking everybody else so there's only
one guy he won't attack even when he is
attacked now I think there's reasons for
that he wants to be the air apparent to
Maga right if this was Celebrity
Apprentice if you watch that when Trump
was the host he wants to be the winner
of that and because Donald Trump will
not be here forever right the guy's
basically 80 years old one way or
another he will not be here forever or
will not be politically relevant forever
but the Maga movement will live on and
VC is Young and he's like okay I want to
make sure I take over that thing I don't
I'm not I'm not even giving him for
that that's that's just fine but this
idea that I'm just not going to attack
him even while I'm being attacked but
I'll Attack everybody else it tells you
a little bit that he really wasn't
running running for president this time
he was running to Curry favor with the
base that I I think that's just kind of
Fairly obvious the problem that they ran
into is that VC has run a nice campaign
it is resonating with young people and
now at the 11th Hour as we're about to
roll into this Iowa caucus Trump's going
oh if he takes five or 10% of those
people from me and de santis has been to
all 99 counties has really great
coordination there and maybe Nikki has
some momentum who knows all the little
pie of it he's going oh that 5 or 10%
actually might mean something so now I
got to go after VC now the idea of trump
turning on someone that he made a deal
with surprise surprise I think VC
hands-off approach maybe not the the
best thing because he could have easily
VC could have easily in response to that
Trump attack uh dunked on Trump over
fouchy over the BLM riots age the wall
the flipping of endorsements all of
those things like if he really if Trump
if VC really believed oh this is my
chance to be president he had a moment
here where he could have gone all in
right uh VC is supposed to be the
America First candidate so you'd think
that he would take the obvious choice
when there's a little bit of movement
anyway Pedro Gonzalez who's been on the
show journalist Pedro Gonzalez he
tweeted this I thought it was kind of
interesting he said Trump humiliated VC
by reminding him that he entered this
race as Trump's stalking horse VC's
response I'm not going to criticize him
followed by graveling that he's Trump's
top guy someone's so chicken he
can't stand up for himself won't stand
up to the regime remember that V has
launched non-stop BS attacks on DeSantis
although DeSantis hasn't really attacked
him at all but after Trump spanks VC in
public VC responds by saying that he is
sorry if the spanking made Trump's hand
sore Beyond pathetic you know the other
piece of this of course is that if you
really believe that the system and I
talk about the system all the time
there's a system that's in place there's
a game being played but if you really
believe the system would not allow Trump
well if you're VC why would the system
allow you right you really have to like
you got to really think it all through
just a bit more on VC and then I want to
get to uh to the governor and Trump uh
because VC is clearly hitting it on the
issues right he is hitting it on the
issues he speaks off the cuff extremely
well right that's what people are are
liking about him I think what they don't
like about him is taking every wi
position right I don't attack
Republicans I attack these guys we
should all be nice blah blah blah anyway
this video pop up this is a guy who was
a big VC supporter who eventually has
now gone back to Trump but he put this
video up comparing VC to Obama and I
thought it was interesting and worth
noting this has never been a Democratic
or republican idea these are not
Democrat ideas or republican ideas this
is an American idea these are
fundamentally American ideals imagine
they were driving a car and and they
they drove it into the ditch if somebody
has repeatedly crashed your car you
can't have the keys back do you want to
turn over the keys to the same people
who crashed it you said Russia in the
1980s are now calling to ask for their
foreign policy back I have a news flash
the USSR does not exist anymore you know
the Cold War has been over for 20 years
it fell back in 1990 that's skinny guy
with a funny name who the heck is this
skinny guy with a funny last name but
they sense deep in their bones I believe
deep in my bones
e out of many one we are one people I
have a dream that we can be one people
again I'm not going to read speeches
written by others what you're going to
get from me is what's coming from the
heart my so first let me just address a
question that is on everybody's mind at
home tonight who the heck is this skinny
guy with a funny last name and what the
heck is he doing in the middle of this
debate okay so now I want to put the
drama portion of this aside I think
there's something interesting Brewing
there and I think it has much more to do
with long-term what happens with Maga
eventually post Trump you know Candace
Owens by the way also has now dumped
Trump and is backing VC it will be
interesting to see if Trump goes after
her now too right so they they are
planning there is a move planning to
take over Maga post Trump and the
question is does Trump win it enough
this time uh to delay that plan we shall
see now I want to get to some danta
stuff but before we do let me talk to
you guys about tax Network USA are you
struggling with back taxes or unfiled
Returns the IRS is escalating
collections adding 20,000 new agents and
sending over 5 million collection
letters to kick off 2024 that's some
good government money for you in these
challenging times your best defense is
tax Network USA don't let the IRS take
advantage of you with over 14 years of
experience tax Network USA has saved
their clients over a billion dollars in
back taxes no matter the size of your
tax issue their expertise is your
advantage they specialize in negotiating
with the IRS aiming to significantly
reduce your debt tax Network USA doesn't
just negotiate they also protect your
assets from IRS seizures and manage to
uh and manage your yearly returns for
ongoing compliance importantly they are
licensed to help with all state tax
issues regardless of where you live in
the US the clock is ticking don't wait
as the IRS steps up its game seize
control of your financial future now
contact tax Network USA for immediate
relief and expert guidance call 1 1800
2456 or visit TN usa.com dve don't let
tax issues over EMP power you turn to
tax Network USA and find your path to a
financial peace of mind and now back to
me okay so now cards on the table in
case you're wondering how I feel about
this whole thing uh there is a guy that
we have been waiting for for a long time
who is a little bit better than the
other guys who's a little bit younger
and who has a bit a little bit of a
better track record who let us out of Co
and all of that stuff and his name is
Ronda santis and he is the governor of
Florida he is America's governor um and
I think he is the best choice so now
let's talk about him for a little bit
first off over the weekend you know he
doesn't get into the drama game right if
you think about all the debates he just
doesn't he he barely got attacked in any
of the debates because they don't have
much to cut him on and he doesn't really
attack back people you know there were
times when be and Nikki screaming at
each other and SAS is going you know
what's the point of all this uh but he
was asked
yesterday he was asked about uh this
Trump VC drama and here's how he
responded you know I noticed that they
um that he threw um um the yeah he threw
him under the bus um you know it's like
I've never seen a candidate run for an
office and basically campaign for
another candidate in the same race
before and that's what's happened but
the minute he wasn't useful you know
they they they they they dropped the
hammer on it so that's just kind of the
way way they are but look we're going to
go forward as a party we can go forward
in a way that's focused on people agenda
for America or we can go forward uh with
Trump which will be focused the 2024
election on legal issues on criminal
trials on convictions on on all these
things with January 6 and that gives the
Democrats um a huge Advantage uh going
forward and I don't think that we want
to do that why would we want to give
them any advantage all right the reason
I wanted to show you that clip is as I
said he doesn't really get involved into
the drama he quickly makes a comment
there and it and it's just true right
like Trump saw VC as useful you're going
to be my guy at the debates that I'm not
going to show up to and you're going to
attack everybody and say we should
always be nice and then also dump on
everybody and you're going to do all
that and then when push got to shove as
I said when we got to the 11th hour now
now Trump is going after VC okay fine
but the real point of of showing you
that clip is what the Santa said after
which is that there is a chance to not
have all of this drama going forward
right and clearly he's the candidate to
do that by the way the two guys that
he's standing in between there Thomas
Massie uh from Kentucky and Chip Roy
from Texas Massie is by far by far not
even close the most Libertarian
liberty-minded uh Congressional member
of Congress in the entire United States
government and Chip Roy from Texas has
the number one most conservative voting
record so those guys are putting their
butts on the line nobody can question
although I guess some of the trumpkin do
whether they they are pro- America or
America first or for Maga or anything
else but what you have right there are
three decent civil servants uh fighting
together at the same time uh Dan santis
went on to talk a little bit about the
media because you know one criticism
that the santis has gotten and I I don't
know that I can blow it up exactly is
that he hasn't run a good campaign it's
not that he isn't competent it's not
that he doesn't do what he's going to
say it's that he doesn't run enough of a
campaign to like get enough clicks and
Views and whatever to get everybody
excited the santis addressed the the
sort of trump kind of deal made in hell
with uh the conservative news pointed
out that criticism do you feel like
that's connecting with voters or do you
feel like they're going to stand with
them despite well here's the thing um
you know this this is not a complaint
this is just an observation like I I
take like when I look at like how you
run a campaign or this I just look at
the world as it is you know there's
going to be certain media against you
obviously certain that he's got
basically a petorian guard of of of the
conservative Media Fox News um you know
the the websites all the this stuff they
just don't they don't hold them
accountable because they're worried
about losing viewers and they don't want
to have the ratings go down uh and
that's just that's just the reality
that's just the truth and I'm not
complaining about it um I'd rather that
not be the case but that's just I think
an objective reality so when you're
saying that who is amplifying the
criticism right I mean if there's you
could be running hey he said this about
fouchy and that could be running and
they could be having big debate and kind
of the conservative media that is not
happening people just act like he never
said any of this stuff when he says have
a build a big beautiful1 billion plus
new headquarters for the FBI in the
center of the swamp that's not draining
the swamp that's deepening the swamp are
they having big debates on these
conservative leaning media about about
how that is not what he uh has
campaigned on in the past no they're not
so that's just that's a re that is kind
of the reason why I think he's able to
do what he's doing yeah if it's just
true it's just true and I I said to
Phoenix when we just played that just
now it's like the line I'm not
complaining it's just an observation
even that he he prefaces it with that
like I'm not complaining about it I'm
I'm out here doing everything I can do
but it is an observation that there is
this guard around Trump right the online
people they know they get clicks from
Trump trump might retweet you or ret
truth you Trump might invite you to Mara
Lago i' I've personally me Dave have
been very close to that thing and it is
nice when when Donald Trump tweeted
about my book it was very nice I've been
to Mar Lago it's nice to go there uh but
that doesn't mean you deserve my
allegiance forever uh Dan santis is
right that there is a machine a machine
in place it's why MSNBC and even though
there he's talking about the
conservative news why does MSNBC talk
about Trump all day long it's because
it's not because they really think he's
Hitler but if you create this idea that
he is Hitler and a fascist and blah blah
blah then you can keep people watching
all day long because they think that you
that they are the ones standing up
against Hitler and what the santis has
done has been like hey I'm I'm a decent
guy I pick the right fights my wife's
kind of hot and we have three kids and
we're cool and there's no drama here and
that isn't as good for clicks so even
the people putting Fox aside for a
second even the people in my space and I
don't need to throw any specific person
under the bus but I get what the
selective pressures are right I know
that I have a certain amount of my
audience pissed at me uh because I
didn't just go all in on Trump right uh
it does but I know also that I have to
live with myself and do what I think is
right and true and that that has brought
us a whole new audience right our
audience is bigger than ever because I
think you guys know what truth is you
know what honesty is and even if it
doesn't work out the way I wanted to I
didn't twist myself into pretzels and
debase myself uh during this whole uh
during this whole process I do want to
mention one other thing which I don't
think I've said publicly I think I said
it on a postgame show once but it's just
worth saying on this one day I'll say it
one time and that's it but 6 months ago
I had and he knows who he is I had one
of the let's say four or five biggest
Trump Maga influencer media people in my
house for coffee in the afternoon about
100 p.m. sitting in our swivel chairs in
the kitchen uh telling me that he was
all in on DeSantis and Trump was too old
and crazy and it was all about revenge
and everything else and then you know
couple weeks pass the tea leaves changed
a little bit and now he's all about
Trump again because it is about clicks
and attention and making money there's
just a truth to that but again I want to
say I I'm only saying that for the same
reason that the santis is saying it it's
not complaining it's an observation that
you have to be able to observe these
things honestly without the fog of
nonsense in front of you so okay let's
that's that um let's let's move to the
next thing Phenix roll with me for a
second here um wait are we doing the
rats we're not doing the rats oh we're
we're skipping something here I want to
jump to a to a tweet I had that was uh
that was viral sorry we got a little
crossed up on the prompter there uh that
I think sums it up quite nicely if I
dare quote myself imagine if there was a
presidential candidate who was in the
prime of his life and won every election
he'd been in the last one in
record-breaking fashion had had an
endless track record of accomplishing
everything he set out to do had led the
country out of covid mania had served in
the military was no nonsense and no
drama and was a fine family man just
imagine that one really really caught
fire and I think it is it is the simple
version of all of this uh I also want to
go back to about 6 months ago when I had
the governor on the show and I asked him
what I think was the most important
question which is how do you take the
Maga people the America first people the
people that absolutely love Trump and
and show them that maybe you are the
best guy your message to the ride or die
Trump people like that the hardcore
magga base that before all of this they
loved you but they're just going with
Trump but you know that you have to get
some of those people to win this thing
well nobody in in the United States in
the Republican party has delivered more
on America First policies and principles
than me uh if you look at immigration
illegal immigration we've banned
Sanctuary cities we've cracked down on
human smuggling we even sent illegal
aliens to beautiful Martha's Vineyard uh
and so we've put our money where our
mouth is you talk about things like
China we've banned and the purchase of
land by the CCP and its Affiliates in
our state we got rid of things like
confucious institutes and we cracked
down on their influence of universities
uh you look at what we've done for
expand second amendment rights with
constitutional carry look at what we've
done to fight uh against the woke agenda
whether it's fighting Disney involving
education or fighting this ESG movement
which is really bad uh for our economy
and for American families the way
they're going after domestic energy prod
C you want to talk about draining the
swamp uh there's one guy in this entire
country that's ever taken action against
Soros backed prosecutors and that's me
and we've removed two of them from
Office uh in the last year year and a
half who were not following the law and
were putting their political agenda over
Public Safety I cleared out the election
supervisors in South Florida when I
became Governor we've banned Zucker
bucks we've banned ballot harvesting we
have Universal voter ID and we even have
an election crimes task force uh police
force in state government which which
prosecutes uh voter fraud so we have the
best election Integrity in the entire
country all right so you get it you've
probably seen that clip before I think
it's a compelling case the people of
Iowa will make that decision for
themselves uh a little bit more here on
uh DeSantis going after Trump in terms
of how much energy Trump has just sort
of sucked up in the universe and sort of
how he operates let's say with ego first
instead of America First you can be the
most worthless Republican in America but
if you kiss the ring he'll say you're
wonderful you can be the strongest most
dynamic uh successful Republican and
conservative in America but if you don't
kiss that ring then he'll try to trash
you you know what you deserve a nominee
that's going to put you first not
himself first
he's just telling the truth and you just
have to decide we all just have to
decide do you want someone to tell you
the truth and put something above
themselves or or do you not now here's a
compilation that basically perfectly
illustrates that if you share one video
that we put up today I think this should
be the
one understands that the job of Attorney
General is to Serve and Protect the
people of the United
States and that is exactly what he will
do and do better than anybody else can
Jeff sessions was a disaster as attorney
general should have never been attorney
general he's not qualified he's not
mentally qualified to be attorney
general we hope Bill bar is going to be
as good as we think because Bill is a
good he's a great gentleman a great man
and by the way when Bill bar who's you
know a coward Bill bar was a coward Bill
bar didn't do what he was supposed to do
I fired him and he has great hatred in
his new role as chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff General Millie will
serve as my top military advisor visor I
have absolute confidence that he will
fulfill his duty with the same
Brilliance and fortitude he has shown
throughout his long and very
distinguished career Millie frankley was
incompetent the last one I'd want to
attack with as my leader would be Milly
John Kelly will do a fantastic job
General Kelly has been a star done an
incredible job thus far respected by
everybody a great great American I know
John Kelly he was with me didn't do a
good job had no temperament and
ultimately he was petered out he got he
was exhausted this man was totally
exhausted he wasn't even able to
function I am confident that Jay has the
wisdom and Leadership to guide our
economy through any challenges that our
great economy May face and you know I
had my own situation with poell and I
beat the hell out of him I was not a big
fan of pal I was he was recommended by
some people I didn't like them all right
guys that's about half of that video now
I don't have Trump derangement syndrome
I voted for Trump derang uh for Trump
derangement I voted for Trump right like
I'm just saying like maybe there is a
better choice and you could say well he
learned he didn't know what the swamp
was going to do but like it's always
about either caving to these people or
is it possible that he's such a genius
and everyone else around him is always
an idiot like do you really think that
that's possible
uh here's one more from DeSantis talking
about how most Republicans are weak and
end up giving everything to Democrats
which kind of that's what we just
Illustrated and I'm sick of Republicans
you see what they're doing right now in
Washington and the with these Senators
doing some border agreement which is
basically caving on everything to the
Democrats these guys get beat by the
Democrats time and time again yeah and
not only does the sanus not get beat by
Dem rats has never lost an election uh
but he's completely obliterated the
Democrat Party in Florida it basically
does not exist the point is that he does
things differently the track record is
there I know you know it but now I want
to illustrate it as it relates to the
Border deal that is in the Senate right
now this is the Schumer Lankford border
deal so this is the Border deal that the
Republicans are signing on or
potentially signing on uh what's it
going to do well it's going to increase
green cards by 50,000 in a year work
permits for adult children of hb1b
holders immediate work permits to every
illegal alien released from custody
think about that one taxpayer funded
lawyers to certain uac's and mentally
incompetent aliens 5,000 migrants per
day allowed into the US restricts parole
for those who enter without
authorization between ports of Entry so
yes the santis is absolutely right the
the Democrats blow but the Republicans
suck and what we have here in Florida is
a now a deeply deeply red state that is
functional and it's paying off its debt
and has no income tax and is sane and we
don't have homeless problems and drug
problems and all of those things and we
protect the First Amendment and the
Second Amendment and maybe we can
blueprint that throughout the country
and that's what could start could could
could start today in Iowa so how is it
that the santis does it differently why
is it that I always tell you guys I
consider a Florida Republican but not a
national Republican well it's mostly
because he doesn't cave like all of the
other Republicans do uh here he is over
the weekend talking about he how he's
not only demolished the Democrat Party
here in Florida which is one thing he's
also completely destroyed the Miami
teachers union as well on Co we beat him
on school
opening and not only that we now have in
Florida enacted paycheck protection for
teachers so no automatic deduction of
school union dues you know what a lot of
teachers are choosing not to pay those
dues and join and you have some of these
major unions like in uh Miami Dade a
radical teacher Union they're on the
brink of decertification so this is what
you call winning on these issues uh
number two we beat fouchy during covid
yeah and again I know you guys get it
the track record is there the competency
is there and everything else so let's
let's get this all caught up to where we
are at today because today is the caucus
as I mentioned it's now -7 in Iowa it's
chilly what that does to turn out most
likely uh it depresses it but you know
people are excited about this thing and
we shall see what happens uh on NBC News
over the weekend believe it or not Chuck
Todd actually said that things could be
trending for DeSantis cold temperatures
so the question is always about turnout
but that adds a new element what are you
going to be watching for tomorrow night
in addition to the weather well but
that's the point here it almost is the
entire ball game turnout because the
smaller the turnout that's when weird
things happen here yes you know Rick
sorm didn't win in a large turnout you
know those sorts of things and Donald
Trump has benefited from Big turnouts he
really you know when we've had the
higher the turnout has been in general
election the better more Trump voters
have come so and is there a uh is there
a complacency issue that Trump has to
worry about so I you know this is a a
question where weather has suddenly
become the entire ball game it should be
a real advantage to Ronda santis here's
the guy that has been building an
organization longer than any other
campaign he's got the governor on his
side who's got a built-in organization
this is why you build an organization is
when the weather drops unexpectedly are
you going to get your people out right
so in theory this is all actually I
think setting up really well right now
for Ronda santz all right I I don't know
why Chuck Todd would say that unless he
thinks it might be true and we know that
the santis has had the best organization
down there all 99 counties they've
they've put the strategy the whole
strategy was that if we do well in Iowa
it shows that Trump can be wounded and
then we can kind of move forward right
now everyone mainstream media and all of
your friends and every we have friends
here this weekend everyone's saying the
exact same thing to me everyone says the
same freaking thing I like Trump most
people say I voted for Trump I what you
know whatever I'm just kind of over it
the santis is the guy but I don't think
it can happen it doesn't seem like can
happen the polls make it seem like it's
never going to happen so what the santis
needs tonight I don't know that he
necessarily needs to win I think a win
would send a massive freaking signal but
if it's close enough it shows oh there
is some damage that could be done there
we thought there was a 50o gap and we
thought that the guy doesn't even have
to debate so that that's really kind of
where we're at right now but but the
other piece of this of course is that
what you need to do when we get to the
the national election is you have to
find new voters right if we are to
believe that the last election was legit
now Donald Trump says it was not he
believes it was stolen which always
makes you think well why wouldn't they
steal it from you again and are you
doing anything to stop that as far as I
know the answer to that is no but if we
are to believe the last election Biden
got 81 million votes and uh Donald Trump
got 75 million okay so you got to find
some new voters are there new people
that are suddenly get into Trump I don't
know I just don't know anyone are there
people that have kind of had it with
Trump yeah Dan santis on the other hand
are there people that are crossover
people that could vote for this guy
there's a ton of evidence that that
actually is the case because we know
what's happened here in Florida the
amount of Democrats who are now
Republicans here in Florida so you've
got to get these center-left people one
of them is a guy like say Joe Rogan this
is not the law the law is that you're
supposed to go through this process
where they vet you and they find off
your criminal and they find out if
you're a terrorist and yeah they're not
doing that at all they're just opening
the border and they're essentially
buying votes yeah they they're doing
this they're they're letting these
people come in and they're assuming
these people are going to vote for the
Democrats M and it's wild it's wild that
it's happening right in front of
everybody's eyes and most people aren't
aware of it unless they see these videos
or like Elon was telling me that when
you go there you really understand the
scope of it he goes it's extraordinary
he just you you can't believe the
numbers of people that are making their
way cross it's just insane it's just and
everyone knows about it so all these
people that live in these and I don't I
don't blame them at all man okay Joe
Rogan a potm smoking mushroom eating
mostly kind of you at this point I think
you call him disaffected liberal as far
as I know he didn't even vote last time
because he didn't want to vote for Biden
and and also didn't want to vote for
Trump I don't know that he has said I
don't think he's going to vote again or
would even get go on the record as
voting for Donald Trump uh but Elon Musk
who he referenced said would vote for
DeSantis would Elon vote for Trump and
it may not matter in the specifics of
whether Joe Rogan or Elon Musk votes for
whoever they vote for but it's they are
the taste makers right so we know that a
certain amount of people can shift
towards a disantis where there's just
that aversion to trump it just is you
may not like it but it just is so the
question is what America First candidate
can actually get some of those people
all of the people who have since October
7th have woken up to what identity itics
have done all of the people who are
seeing violence on our streets again and
Border um Bridges being closed and
everything else an attack on the white
house this weekend by pramas supporters
we're not even covering that today
because it's just happening over and
over and over again but the big issue
here is who can beat Joe Biden and Joe
Biden is a weak president he is a liar
no one thinks he's in charge he's old
all of that stuff and here he is just
flat out lying about illegal immigration
right to your face Mr President you call
the situation on the southern border
of no but I would say with react I've
been pushing them my Republican
colleagues since I got in office I think
we have to make a major changes in the
Border he's telling you that there's no
crisis we know there's a crisis I show
you the videos every day you see the
videos every day thousands of people are
walking through they are fighting age
they are largely male they are not
bringing women and children with them
there are no old people we don't know
where the hell these people are we give
them a phone and we say go to San Diego
so the point is that but Joe Biden he's
weak he's old he's controlled but he's
dangerous he actually is dangerous
whether it's intentional with him or not
so we need someone who can actually beat
him uh let's not forget that Joe Biden
whether he's pulling the strings or not
he has had some of the most
authoritarian impulses and policies you
can possibly imagine let's not forget
this one from the middle of
Co but I need
you the American people I need you I
need every American to do their part and
that's not hyperbole I need you I need
you to get vaccinated when it's your
turn and when you can find an
opportunity and to help your family your
friends your neighbors get vaccinated as
well because here's the
point if we do all this if we do our
part we do this together by July the 4th
there's a good chance you your families
and friends will be able to get together
in your backyard or in your neighborhood
and have a cookout and a barbecue and
celebrate independence day that doesn't
mean large events with lots of people
together but it does mean small groups
will be able to get
together I wish you could have heard
some of the things we were saying about
him while that video was playing I mean
the worst author you will maybe be able
to get together on in your backyard with
your family to celebrate independence
day it's worth noting those old videos
because those are the impulses that Joe
that Joe Biden whether it's Joe Biden or
whoever is pulling the strings that he
has and that he undoubtedly would
unleash on us in a in a second
Administration in a second term right
like there's just no doubt about that
whether he even survives it he could
fall up the stairs today and then we
have a whole different situation on our
hands uh but of course the vaccines
didn't work and everything else and that
he even connected it to Independence Day
when Independence Day should be about
fighting authoritarian people like him
and everything else but of course the
other part of this is that something is
wrong with the man's brain it is sad but
it is true he is the pilot of the plane
and I would prefer if my pilot was
competent and cogent this man is not any
comment on the political change in
Poland as the new pro-european Union
government is taking over I think that's
very
good oh I think that like he just
doesn't know what's going on the fact
that they put him okay fine you get it
we don't have to belabor the point on
Biden today uh but what of course will
the machine do the there is a there is a
match made in hell with the machine and
Trump right as I said earlier they tell
you he's Hitler and they know he drives
the most clicks and the most views so
they tell you he's Hitler they tell you
he's evil and then they want you to
think about him all day long the thing
that that the machine if you want to
talk about the machine or the system the
thing that the machine or the system
would fear the most is a competent
Republican who was no drama who went out
there and put forth sensible
conservative policies that actually made
sense that's what the machine would fear
because they wouldn't know what to do
with it wait they'd be like Oh uhoh The
Border's starting to uh be taken care of
uhoh the economy is starting to work
uhoh there's no drama here uhoh he's
younger and speaks in full sentences
uhoh uhoh it's not about him all time
they would not know what to do with that
that would not be good for CNN it would
not be good for MSNBC and everything
else so Trump is sort of in it it's just
it's just true if you can if you can
clear some of the fog here so anyway
what does the mainstream media do it
keeps you focused on how evil Trump is
because that's the thing that they think
can drive in a Joe Biden the most easily
right they don't want to have to deal
with a a a candidate on the Republican
side who can cross over who who doesn't
just give them the red meat that they
want here is Nancy Pelosi on Trump and
you'll be shocked to hear her comments
this is a neck and neck race and no one
feels very comfortable on the Democratic
side of things that Donald Trump isn't
going to be the next
president well I don't think that nobody
feels I think many of us know that it is
impossible uh for him to be the
president again with what he is
proposing that's an interesting comment
many of us know it's impossible how does
she know that how does she know it's
impossible do the people vote in America
or does that feel like a little bit of
predictive program right like they are
going to stop this guy no matter what
but the the the overriding point The
Meta point is they must keep you
terrified now I have no doubt ultimately
that even if DeSantis would became
president would they would they use some
of the same tactics on him yes of course
they have right we've shown you many
compilations over the last year of where
they're basically calling disantis Trump
with a they're calling him Hitler with a
calculator right he's like Trump but
he's competent it's even worse so I have
no doubt that they would do that too the
problem is that Trump is just constantly
giving them the red meat I want to show
you a video that we showed you last week
Michelle Obama uh trying to ramp up the
fear with the people because without the
fear they basically got nothing it's not
their policies that work it's not any of
their Outlook or philosophy or anything
else it's fear you know are we moving at
all fast enough what are we doing about
education are people going to vote and
why aren't people voting are we too
stuck to our phones I mean those are the
things that me up because you don't
control over them and you wonder where
are people where are we in this you know
where are our hearts what's going to
happen in this next election I am
terrified about what could possibly
happen because our leaders matter who we
select who speaks for us who holds that
bullied pull pit it affects us in ways
that sometimes I think people take for
granted you know the fact that people
think that government H you know is it
does it really even do anything and I'm
like oh my God does government do
everything for us and we cannot take
this democracy for
granted God on one hand she's telling
you government does everything and then
she's telling you we can't take it for
granted it's so crazy no government is
the problem not the solution the less
government the better the smaller the
government is means that you the people
that we the people are doing more for
ourselves
when the government comes knocking on
your door one day it's most likely for a
bad reason I am not an anarchist I don't
believe in no government right but it
should be slim and it should be trim but
she needs you to think that Hitler is on
the way and the only thing that can
protect you is her government that is
deeply deeply dangerous so they're
predictive programming us with this
stuff they're telling you he's evil he's
Hitler because he is the easiest guy
Trump is the easiest this guy to kneecap
they know that a certain amount of
people hate him they know that a certain
amount of people have Trump Arrangement
syndrome rightly or wrongly and again
I'm not one of those people but I can
see the game for what the game is they
did it once with Trump and they will do
it again and he I don't think he has
campaigned in a way that has made it
compelling to anyone who sees anything
that I've talked about here and said
okay come to my side now and I I've got
I've leveled up I've gotten better he
hasn't right like where in this campaign
did he try to get new voters where did
he try to assure people that actually
like imagine if he had just done this
this entire time with all his popularity
imagine if he had not gone scorched
Earth onto santis and lied about Florida
and lied about covid and all that stuff
imagine if he had been like yeah you
know my whole family moved down to
Florida and he is a pretty great
governor and we all know that I just
think that I deserve a second chance
because I'm the leader of America First
and because I'm a billionaire I have
less chance of being influenced blah
blah blah let's let's see what happens
with the santis we would not be in this
thing we would not be in this crazy
thing that is absolutely true but
instead Trump has just become red meat
endlessly for the machine which calls
him a dictator and then also tells you
that you must watch them as they scare
the out of you and he's made it
absolutely plain uh he'll be dictator on
day one and that's the way he wants it
be clear running against Donald Trump
who I suspect will be the Republican
candidate is one of the most dangerous
political figures in modern American
history so no this is real uh it's not
your team this is not the NFL playoffs
and you wear a jersey of one team
whatever Donald Trump is a threat to the
democracy and there's too many people
that are following that Donald is a very
vindictive human being just take a look
at some of the statements that he made
if you punch him he wants to hit you
back 10 times harder that's who he is
now of course he won't do it himself he
will just have SEAL Team Six do it all
right guys that was his former lawyer
look I think I think that out of all of
the people that you might watch during
this during any primary season or that
you watch to get any kind of sense out
of the news I think I have tried to
consistently do this as honestly as
possible I got one more video for you
but the Iowa caucus is tonight we could
really write the ship starting today it
is possible is it going to happen I
don't know is is the thing that I
believe in that I've been fighting for
does it seem to really be outside of
what most people are going to say is
going to happen tonight yes absolutely
do I believe that it is worth fighting
for the right thing regardless yeah I do
and I think you do too so the choice is
yours like that's that's where we're at
that's where we're at you may be all
Maga all the time and you might watch
the video of him telling you Miley is
great and Miley is horrible and but he
learned this like all of that stuff but
if you care about America first if you
if you want to fix the border and the
economy and all of those things like we
got a chance to do it it's a better
chance and I I think most people know it
in their hearts and that is why I'm a
bit bullish on tonight for Dan santis
because I think when people get into
those gymnasiums and into those churches
and into those community centers and
they get to talk to their neighbors I
think people are going to go you know
what let's try it this way I might be
wrong I don't know we'll see what
happens tomorrow morning I suppose well
we'll see what happens tonight and we'll
see how I'm behaving tomorrow morning
but I want to leave you with this
because you know they always say they
always say in every election what do
they say this is the most important
election this is the election of a
lifetime and usually if we were to look
back at the last however many years it's
just not true this one really does feel
different if if you look at the
destruction that that has rought across
this country in the last couple years
from the border to the economy to just
the the to what Dei has done to
everything to The Strife on our streets
like Up Is Down left is right boys or
girls like so many freaking problems and
it's not that problems can all be solved
by politicians
um but sometimes if you do something in
your life to to fight for the right
thing then once in a generation
candidate can come around and the
country can be uh can be course
corrected that's where we're at Ronald
Reagan's probably his most famous speech
was his time for choosing speech and I
thought we'd play just a little bit of
it for you right
here ladies and gentlemen we take pride
in presenting a a thoughtful address by
Ronald Reagan Mr
Reagan thank
you thank you very
much thank you and good evening the
sponsor has been identified but unlike
most television programs the performer
hasn't been provided with a script as a
matter of fact I have been permitted to
choose my own words and discuss my own
ideas regarding the choice that we face
in the next few weeks I have spent most
of my life as a Democrat I recently have
seen fit to follow another course I
believe that the issues confronting us
cross party
lines now one side in this campaign has
been telling us that the issues of this
election are the maintenance of peace
and prosperity the line has been used
we've never had it so good but I have an
uncomfortable feeling that this
Prosperity isn't something on which we
can base our hopes for the Future No
nation in history has ever survived a
tax burden that reached a third of its
national income today 37 cents out of
every dollar earned in this country is
the tax collector share and yet our
government continues to spend $17
million a day more than the government
takes in and we we could have shown you
much more of that and I hope you'll
watch it on it on your own the full
speech but I wanted to just show you a
portion of that because that really was
the defining speech 1974 Reagan who of
course then became governor and then
ultimately president um but but the the
overriding point guys is that he was a
good decent man there is another good
decent man out there who's saying some
hard truths who has a track record of
winning the Reagan thing is particularly
interesting to me because he was a
lifelong Democrat and he was loved by
Hollywood and he was loved by the
mainstream media then he switches to a
Republican and ended up being hated you
kind of know that story right so Ians if
you're watching this like get out there
and do the right thing and imagine if we
all just woke up tomorrow and it was a
little bit different it was like oh
there is a chance like maybe there is
this Republican who's going to set the
agenda and it's going to be a little bit
different and less of the drama if there
was a little bit of Hope there and then
suddenly whatever craziness was coming
out of the Democrat side whether it was
Biden or anyone else it would feel a
little less important because we like oh
we have something good that we can all
kind of fight for and I and I believe
that the America First Trump people
because it's not the Trump it's not the
Trump base that I I I wish that Trump
was as good good as the ba to the Bas as
the Bas is to him when he lies to the
Bas and turned everybody against the
STIs the bass knows it's not true
they're just going with Trump there is a
better way there there is a better way
guys uh real quick guys uh I'm on with
Megan Kelly for the hour in just a few
minutes so there's not going to be a a
postgame show uh we're cutting it a
little too close and people of the
internet will be on at 2 pm today also
because of Megan Kelly thing anyway we
leave you with a little bit of Joe Biden
being a freak and Iowa do the right
thing ciao confidence secretary Austin I
do I'm sorry I'm trying to sff your hair
was it ation judgment for not to tell
you earlier
yes